[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدي الكرام كم مره قال
الرئيس الامريكي ان الرئيس السوري فقد
شرعيته بعد ان تمر البلاد وذبح العباد
مرات ومرات طيب اذا كان بلا شرعيه فلماذا
تريدون من المعارضه السوريه ان تفاوض
الاسد اليس مؤتمر جنيف بمثابه اعاده تاهيل
لب الاعتذار للنظام ومباركه لما فعله
بسوريا والسوريين على مدى ثلاثين شهرا
لماذا لم تطلب من المعارضه المصريه مثلا
ان تتفاوض مع مبارك وهو الذي لم يدمر
بيتنا مصريا واحدا بينما شرد الاسد ملايين
السوريين ودمر بيوتهم وذبح مئات الالوف
منهم مع ذلك تريدون من الشعب ان يفاوض اه
اليس المعارضون ال موافقون على جنيف شركاء
في ذبح الشعب السوري هل يتوقعون من النظام
ان يسلمهم الجيش واجهزه الامن التي رباها
لحمايته شخصيا منذ عشرات السنين هل من
ضمانات مع نظام تعود على الكذب والخداع
والمماطله يصلح ضيفنا اليس اقصى ما يمكن
ان يقدمه الاسد لمعارضيه وزاره المزابل
القوميه
لكن في المقابل الم يصل الوضع الميداني
بين المعارضه والنظام الى طريق مسدود لا
النظام قادر على الحسم ولا المعارضه هل
لدى المعارضه اي بديل للتفاوض اليس
التفاوض على تقاسم السلطه هو الحل الامثل
اليس هناك اجماع دولي على ان الحل العسكري
مستحيل في سوريا لاسباب عسكريه وسياسيه
ومذهبيه هل هناك معارضه سوريه المتحده
اصلا للتحدث باسم السوريين اليست مجرد
جماعات تابعه لهذا البلد او ذاك الم تثبت
تجارب بلدان الربيع العربي ان انكسار طرف
على طرف سيؤدي الى مزيد من الخراب والدمار
الا يجب على المعارضين السوريين ان
يتعلموا من التجربه العراقيه
اسئله اطرحها على الهواء مباشره على السيد
محمود مرعي امين عام تيار سوريون من اجل
الديمقراطيه رئيس المنظمه العربيه لحقوق
الانسان
وعلى السيد لؤي المقداد المنسق السياسي
والاعلامي للجيش الحر نبدا النقاش بعد
الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدي الكرام نحن معكم
على الهواء مباشره في برنامج الاتجاه
المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على موضوع هذه
الحلقه هل تؤيد التفاوض مع النظام السوري
في مؤتمر جنيف 2 ثمنطاش بالمائه نعم اثنان
وثمانون بالمائه لالو بدات بهذه التي جمعت
بين المقداد هل يعقل ان يكون هناك اه
حوالي يعني اثنين وثمانين بالمائه واكثر
من اثنين وثمانين بالمائه ضد التفاوض مع
النظام بالرغم مما وصلت اليه الاوضاع في
سوريا من بؤس على كل الصعد بالتاكيد يعني
هي الفتره الصحيحه هي الفكره الصحيحه
للشعب السوري التي اطلقت الثوره السوريه
هي الفتره للطالب معنا بشار الاسد جلال
بشار الاسد كذاب بشار الاسد لا يريد ان
يفاوض لا يريد ان ينتقل بسوريا
للديمقراطيه يريد ان يكذب ويقتل سوريا
ويستمر في هذا المسلسل من الدماء وهم
يعلمون تماما ان الذهاب الى جنيف بشار
الاسد بهذه الحاله سيزيد من حجم قتلهم وس
يعطي مزيدا من الدفاع الى بشار الاسد الذي
يقتلهم لكن هذه المره بشرعيه دوليه بعدما
الدوليه نعم سيكتشف شرعيه دوليه بشار
الاسد اذا ذهبت المعارضه السوريه الى جنيف
وفق هذا المبدا ووفق بضمانات واضحه بان
بشار الاسد المجرم ونظامه سيرحلون ستكون
شرعيه لبشار الاسد ليقتل اكثر سيصل بين
المجتمع الدولي الى مرحله التي كان يستحيل
بشار الاسد دليل الحياه ان يستخدم اكثر من
ثلاثه صواريخ السكود باليوم سيستخدم عشرات
للسكوت يوميا سيقتل بالسلاح الكيميائي
شرعيا هذه المره وليس كما كان يقتل بقليل
من الخجل او الاستحياء او يكذب على الاقل
بان يبرر هذا القرار كنا سمعنا اليوم من
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي والبريطاني او
وزيري الخارجيه الامريكي والبريطاني يقول
ان في مؤتمر اصدقاء سوريا ان لا مكان
للاسد في سوريا المستقبل باي حال من
الاحوال وهي بعد ان يعني بعد مرحله ساعات
الساعات بعد ساعات لتكون الضربه من قبل
اوباما وبعد ان وصلنا الى هذه المرحله من
الكذب والتسويف والصفقات الدوليه اعتقد
انه من اليوم ورايح ما نتعامل مع المجتمع
الدولي
رئيسه واثنين الشهود ويصادق عليه حكيمه
اللي بيقول لا مكان لبشار الاسد لتخرج
وثيقه واضحه من مجلس الامن وتحت الفصل
السابع او بضمانات دوليه واضحه يوقعوا
كلنا عليها اتفضلوا هذه الضمانات اما وهنا
لا نكون واضحين مع اسمح لي احكي الشارع
اذا كانت المشكله اليوم كل السوريين
يريدون حلا ومن غير المسموح ان ينظر احد
من خارج سوريا على حساب الدماء السوريين
على حساب اطفال اللي مع الضمنيه ولا على
حساب ذريه ولا حمص المحاصره لكن يا جماعه
جنيف ليس الحل جنيف تسويق لقتلكم جنيف
بهذا الشكل سيكون المزيد والمزيد من دمار
سوريا والمزيد من اعطاء الوقت ل بشار
الاسد لا يستطيع احد ان يقول عندما رفعت
هذه الثوره السوريه منذ اليوم الاول نفس
هذا التصدق به الشعب السوري مصلحته قالت
مالنا غيرك يا الله لانها تعلم ان الجميع
يكذب الجميع يحدث وليس هناك من حل في جنيف
بل جنيف يريدونها كذبه جديده وتسويه جديد
واخبار جديده السيد ماذا تقول لهذه النسبه
اثنين انت قادم من دمشق وانت مع الذين
يعني يؤيدون الذهاب الى جنيف والحل السلمي
والى ما هنالك من ها الكلام ماذا تقول
لهؤلاء الغربيه العظمى بالرغم من كل ما
حصل للشعب السوري من من ماسي يعني لم تحدث
في تاريخ الحديث اثنان وثمانون بالمائه
الى جنيف اعتقد ان هذا التصويت هو تصويت
على الفيس بوك لا علاقه له بالشارع السوري
الشارع السوري وخاصه الكتل الصامته في
سوريا وفي المدن السوريه توري بالخلاص
وتريد جنيف اما ال الذين يعيشون خارج
سوريا ممكن ان يقولوا لا ل جنيف لكن ما هو
البديل لا بديل لديهم نحن نعتقد ان جنيف
ممكن ان يشكل مخرجا او حلا سياسيا واخراج
سوريا من ازمتها السياسيه ومن الحرب
العبثيه وال كارثيه التي تعيشها سوريا
بدون جنيف ما في حل قناعه لدى الشعب
السوري ان الحل هو حلا سياسيا
ويجب ان يجلس الطرفين الى طاوله التفاوض
من اجل اخراج سوريه من ازمتها الراهنه
والا سوف تستمر القتل والتدمير والذبح
واستمرار القتال ونحن نعتقد ان للنظام
قادره على انهاء العمل المسلح والمسلحين
ولا المسلحين قادرين على اسقاط النظام اذن
نحن في حرب كارثيه لا معنى لها مزيد من
القتل مزيد من التدمير ومزيد من انت انت
انت ت يعني تريد ان تذهب الى جنيف لكن هل
يريد النظام ان يذهب الى جنيف النظام اه
وانا نذهب الى جنيف باتفاق تولي لا علاقه
للنظام وللمعارضه في جنيف جنيف 1 تم بحضور
دول دائمه العضويه الخمسه او هل طبقوا
جنيف واحد في تذهبوا الى جنيف لم يطبق
جنيف 1 الان جنيف 2 يؤسس على جنيف 1 جنيف
واحد لم يطبقه خاصه الامريكان فسروا عده
الثرات واختلفوا مع الروس على تفسير جنيف
1 الان اتفقوا الان اتفقوا وعلى ما يبدو
هناك موعد يحضر الى جنيف 2 باتفاق روسي
امريكي مع الدول الدائمه العضويه في مجلس
الامن وبحضور الدول الاقليميه ودول الجوار
نحن م حل سياسي ومحلل سياسي وان لم يكن
هناك اتفاق
دولي واقليمي على اخراج سوريا من ازماتها
لا لا لن تخرج لن تخرج الصراع صراع كارثه
وعبثا ولا معنى له مزيد من القتل ومزيد من
التدمير للشعب السوري كيف ترد على هذا
الكلام انت خائف من الذهاب الى جنيف وتقول
انه سيكون يعني نوعا من التشريع على القتل
اذا صح التعبير او مباركه للنظام او في
احسن الاحوال يعني اعتذار للنظام عن ما
فعله بالسوريين على مدى اكثر من ثلاثين
شهرا الرجل يقول لك نحن ذاهبون الى جنيف
بدعم وتاييد دولي هناك اراده دوليه واراده
اقليميه واراده عربيه
الجميع يقول لك لا حل عسكريا في سوريا
الحل سياسي ماذا تقول لهم يا سيدي اولا
يعني باعتبار الاستاذ محمود عم بيقول انه
الاغلبيه السابقه في سوريا مع هذا الحل
اللي عم بيحكي فيه
خليكم بالشارع
ليش
على اغلبيه بتحكي غير معكم يعني قريبا
ما هي سلطه انت حكيت مع شو بدها يعني انت
وانت قلت لكم الاغلبيه السلطه انه هي جنيف
هناك شعب يقاتل يا سيدي وانت تعلم ان هناك
شعب يقاتل هناك شعب يقاتل من دعا الى ادله
ومن دير الزور الى اللاذقيه هذا الشعب
يعني جنيف يعني هو يقاتل اجل الذهاب الى
جنيف
يا سيدي الحل لا يكون لا في جنيف ولا في
مكان اخر لانك انت تعلم انه اذا بتروح
بشار الاسد وكل النظام وتاخذ ونائب رئيس
وزراء بشار الاسد تصعيد
ما بيكونوا على حرص سوريا على النظام
مناطق الجيش ال السؤال هل ستطبق قراركم في
جنيف اذا التفات وانتم بشار الاسد ايام
هؤلاء اطلاق النار هدول او ابتدا اطلاق
النار لانهم يحملون انفسهم من بشار الاسد
منذ اليوم الاول وهم يقولون الله اكبر
وسيسقط هذا الظالم طب انت اليوم
من حلها بدون ما الاشكال مائه وخمسين الف
شهيد بشار الاسد منذ عام تتذكر خطابه
الشهير المعطوب عندما قال هناك اربعه
وستين الف وكثير اه ارهابي في سوريا
مائه وخمسين الف يعني اتى وهو
وعشره الاف ولكنها ما خلص يا اخي يعني هلا
ما بدنا هناك شعب ثائر هل اثناء كثير من
اجل التفاوض وصفقه مقاتله مع المجرم بحقه
الاغلبيه السابقه في سوريا لا تستطيع ان
تتكلم اساسا وانت تعلم ان الاغلبيه السلطه
التي يتكلم عنها في السجن او بيقتل او
بيصير معه يحاصر ويجوع ويدل وتشرد اطفاله
وتقتل اطفاله من الجوع اليوم ان تكون
الجنين
احنا بالنسبه اذا كان الحل يمكن بينكم
وبين الشعب السوري في الداخل باعتبار ان
حنا معارضه خارجيه كيف
ما الهو داخل ومن هو الخارج اذا كان الحل
الشعب السوري يرضى به نحن جميعا بما يامر
به الشعب السوري وكلنا ندعي تمثيل الشعب
السوري
ليس هناك احد منتخب اليوم في سوريا
يدعى هذا التمثيل ما هو بما نطق باللسان
الشعب السوري بس يطلع الاهداف بيصير وسائل
جميل جدا من فوضت للذهاب الى جنيف من تمثل
انت على الارض في سوريا انتم مجموعه يعني
انتم هيئه التنسيق انت كنت في هيئه
التنسيق الماضيه كنت في ايه التنسيق انت
شو راح لكم من الاعراب على الارض مين ب
مين مشتركون بين اصلا مع احترام للكلمه
يعني شو بتعمل يعني اجابه عم نس تفاوض
طبعا اه انا كنت
استقلت من هيئه التنسيق منذ اكثر من عام
وهيئه التنسيق هي جزء من المعارضه
الداخليه في سوريا و لها امتداد في الخارج
هذه ال هذه الهيئه تمثل بعض ال الاحزاب
التقليديه
ولها اه جزء بسيط من التمثيل في الشارع
السوري
هيئه التنسيق لا لا انا ما بدي ادافع عن
التنسيق اني اكمل ابدا عن موضوع
الاحزاب
هيئه التنسيق في حزب الاتحاد الاشتراكي
حزب الاتحاد الاشتراكي انا من حزب الاتحاد
الاشتراكي كان من اقدم الاحزاب والكل
بيعرف انه كان شعبيه وجماهيريه كبيره لكن
حاليا حتى حزب الاتحاد الاشتراكي
القسم اربع خمس اقسام وهو ولايه التنسيق
في جزء جزء بسيط من حزب الاتحاد الاشتراكي
قياده تاريخيه بهيئه التنسيق اذن هيئه
التنسيق تمثل جزء بسيط من المعارضه
الداخليه والائتلاف الوطني يمثل جزء من ال
والائتلاف الوطني ايضا يمثل جزء من
المعارضه اذن كل هذه المعارضه لا تمثل
الشعب السوري والمعارضه هناك اطراف وقوى
سياسيه خارجيه التنسيق وخارج الائتلاف هي
جزء من هذه المعارضه المعارضه السوريه
ممزقه متشدده اوضاعها صعبه تحتاج تحتاج
هذه المعارضه الى مؤتمر كمؤتمر القاهره
واحد الذي حضر به
اطياف المعارضه
وصدر عن مؤتمر القاهره وثيقه القاهره
ووثائق القاهره انا مع وثائق القاهره وما
نتج عن وسائق القاهره اذا تسمح لي اما
بالنسبه للجيش السوري الحر للاسف الشديد
الجيش السوري الحر حاليا يمثل حاله بسيطه
ممن يحملون السلاح في سوريا هناك داعش
هناك النصره والقاعده
داعش تسيطر على محافظه الرقه و على جزء
كبير من
خمسه بالمائه
داعش تسيطر على كل محافظه الرقه
وتسيطر على حوالي نصف محافظه دير الزور
وجزء من الحسكه وجزء من حلب وجزء من ادلب
وجزء من اللاذقيه هناك قوس واشار العالم
بشار الاسد
تسيطر على شريط معين من دير الزور الى
ادله
وايضا القاعده والنصره موجودين اذن الجيش
الحر للاسف الشديد سيطروا على اه الرقه
واعتقلوا مقاتلين الجيش الحر سيطروا على
الاعزاز
واعتقل الجيش الحر اذن هناك صراع بين
العسكر و من يحمل السلاح ويدعي انه يمثل
الثوره نحن خرجنا بالثوره سلميا خرجنا
بالثوره من اجل الحريه والقران على شغله
حتى الان لم تجب على سؤالي انت مع من
تفاوض
نحن نفاوض عن الشعب السوري الشان
نحن نخاطب
ونتحدث باسم الشعب السوري انا موجود بدمشق
وبعرف المواطن شو بده المواطن في سوريا
يريد الخلاص بعد اعداد التي ذكرتها من ال
من من من الشهداء والضحايا بعد الجرحى
هناك اعداد كبيره من الجرحى الستين الف
عافيه سوريا اربعه ونصف مليون مهاجر داخلي
اذن
نحن امام كارثه اكيد سوريا تعيش كارثه انا
اريد باختصار انا اريد اولا وقف القتال و
هدر الدم بال سوريا على الارض السوريه انا
حريص
باختصار شديد وضع كارثي بكل المقاييس اذن
الذهاب الى جنيف الا يكون بمثابه عفا الله
عن كل ما فعل في سوريا وبصوره
جمله واحده بجمله واحده هناك عداله
انتقاليه يجب ان تطبق في سوريا تريد ان
اشرح العداله الانتقاليه خلينا شو رايك
بهذا الكلام هذا الكلام كل هذا الكلام مش
كلام يا دكتور
لكن انا اطالب اليوم وقف اطلاق نار من بدا
باطلاق النار ومن قتل مائه وخمسين الف ومن
دمر ثمانيه ثمانيه مليون سوري ومن دمر نصف
سوريا من ضرب سوريا بالكيماوي لم يفعلها
شارون اليوم اللي بتقول لي اه والله وقف
اطلاق نار يعني احنا كنا عم نطلق النار في
المستوى اللي هو
هناك من دمر سوريا اليوم الى وقف اطلاق
نار وعداله انتقاليه
فيها سلميه يا استاذ ملاحظات
بشار الاسد ما في اطلاق نار كان لم يكن
هناك اطلاق نار الورقه واطلعت فيها سلميه
استمر القتل يعني هو
انا مع تغيير في بدايه الثوره مع تغيير
كنا وقلناها وعلى الاعلام مع الجزيره مع
تغيير بنيه هذا النظام من بنيه نظام شمولي
دكتاتوري الى بنظام ديمقراطي
في نقطه مهمه
اللي عم بتوضع النظام يجيب هديل و شهرزاد
ولونا الشبل منحطه يسلمون النظام لو كان
غيرنا الحقيقيه يا استاذ هيكل
النظام
يعيد انتاج بشار الاسد يعني نعيد بالمائه
من مائه وخمسين الف هذه المؤسسات
الاجراميه مخابرات الجيش وعسكري
اكمل هذه النقطه مهمه
نظام بعد هذا ال ايغال بالقتل بعدما وصل
لهون لا رجعه
هذا النظام قطع كل
طيب انت تعلم ان الجميع يدرك الان ان يعني
لا الجيش الحر
هذا النظام قادر على الحسم يا سيدي اذا
اذا انت قدره النظام روح العالي خلق
بديل
عن جميع بديله
مقاومه مسلحه
هل تستطيع ان تنكر ان هناك مزاج دوليا
كاملا ليس مع ليس مع الجميع يعزف على وتر
الحل ال ال ال ال ال التفاوض انت مين معه
ما هو بديله اعطيني بديلا يعني هو هدول
الجميع من فرض عليهم اساسا ان ياتوا ب
بشار الاسد لكي يتفاوض اليس الصور على
الارض واللي
بيطلع هذا البعثه قدري جميل بيطلع يقول لن
نسمح للنظام الذهاب لوحده الى جنيف انما
يحاول حاله منروح ما انت نائب رئيس مجلس
الوزراء عنده على اساس
يروح يفاوض بشار الاسد ما انت وزير اقتصاد
نائب رئيس الوزراء يقول انا مضطر بالدين
بدنا نشوف موضوع من احدى محاضر الجلسات
اللي وصلنا بطريقه معينه وحضر لقاء جلسه
سريه ل وليد المعلم مع السيد هوشيار
زيباري وزير الخارجيه الجمهوريه العراقيه
بغداد الاحد سته وعشرين ايار 2013
من الجانب السوري السيد اللواء محمد ناصيف
معاون نائب رئيس الجمهوريه
السيد السفير سلطان جدعان
سفير سوريا في بغداد السيد جمعه مدير مكتب
من الجانب العراقي ماذا يقول وليد المعلم
اما التنحي لا نقبل به ولا يستطيع احد ان
يذهب للمشاركه في مؤتمر جنيف 2 بدون توجيه
من مين التوجيه الدكتور من الرئيس من
المجالات اللي رئيس من
والتوجيه بحد ذاته يعطي دورا لرئيس
الجمهوريه
نحن مؤمنون بانه لا احد في الكون يقرر
بالنيابه عن الشعب السوري واذا كان
الله
حكومه كامله الصلاحيات
ماذا يعرف النظام حكومه كانت الصلاحيه
في صلاحياتها كامله مع هذا الجيش والقوات
المسلحه فهي من صلاحيات رئيس الجمهوريه
القائد الاعلى للجيش والقوات المسلحه
وهو امر ليس غريب
اما فيما يخص انعقاد مؤتمر جنيف
لا ما لدينا من اطلاق الحوار المباشر هناك
ولكن باعتباره سيستغرق وقتا ويحتاج الى
تشكيل لجان مخصصه لماذا لا يبدا المؤتمر
في جنين ثم ينتقل الى دمشق مع ضمانات
كامله للمعارضه برعايه الجميع برعايه جميل
بالزاويه
الطاوله
يا سيدي رؤيتهم الاولى الحكومه كانت
الصلاحيات وفق دستور
دستور
الذي يوضع كل الصلاحيات
كل شيء
يعني يستمر القصف بمعنى للناس
خليني اخذ النقطه سيد محمود انت ابن سوريا
بتعرف سوريا
اخر احصائيه عن تركيبه الجيش السوري وردت
في جريده الحياه وقلناها اكثر من مره هناك
الف ومائتين وخمسين ضابط امير في الجيش
السوري الف ومائه ضابط علوي ما بدنا نحكي
طائفه المشكله في سوريا المشكله بسوريا
اللي بيحكي عن طائفيه ويحذر منها يصبح
عميل الموساد وستين الف
اما اللي بيمارس الطائفيه من خمسين سنه
ولا عن ابو السوريين على اساس طائفي
اه هذا مش طائفي انا بدي اسالك انت رايح
على شريف فيك تقول هذا الجيش يجب ان يكون
تحت سلطه الشعب السوري وليس تحت سلطه
طائفه تحت سلطه العلويين في كل هذا الكلام
دقيقه هل تستطيع ان تقول له المفاوض
السوري اللي شيء كل اجهزه الامن السوريه
بيد العلويين هل فيك تاخذي من العناوين
خلينا
على جنيف مش ان يعطوا كوزاره المجادله
القوميه والبلاليه الاستراتيجيه هلا انت
شويه يعطيك جنيف اذا رحت نظام صلوا خمسين
سنه يصرف كل شيء على الجيش وعلى امنه شو
بدو يعطيك ربك شو بدو يعطي وحافظ بشار
الاسد بدو يتسم لك على المخابرات التعاون
انت بتعرف ليس هناك من الفرقه في سوريا او
ضابط امن اي شيء انا علوي الاعلى وهذه
السوريه خلوا يسمعوها الان خلونا يسمعوها
ان تكون العلويين فيه تفكك النظام العلوي
هذا
هذا سؤال وصل الى تسعه الاف مره من
اولا
جنيف هي ايران الدوليه
والتفاوض في جنيف تحت المظله الدوليه
الامريكيه الروسيه انا
خليني
خليني خليني
تفاوض هناك اراده دوليه و اشراف دولي و
ضمانات دوليه على التفاوض انا مع نفاوض
النظام بدمشق انا
عنيفه هناك هناك اراده دوليه
بمجلس امن الدول الدائمه العضويه الخمسه
في مجلس الامن وافقت على جنيف 1 وعلى
المقررات السته من هاي المقررات ست الى
تشكيل حكومه انتقاليه هذا الجسم يمارس
كافه الصلاحيات التنفيذيه
لا لا لا لا انا ما عندي الناس
اول شيء
نحنا نحنا
جنيف 1 نسخه
وليد المعلم وزيباري ما بيهمني هذا
الموضوع لانه وقت اللي بيكون فيه اتحاد
روسي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والدول
دائمه العضويه في
يعني
النظام النظام والمعارضه والكل في ضمانات
دوليه و اشراف دولي على الخروج من هذه
الازمه
حكومه كامله الصلاحيات يعاد من خلال اعاده
هيكله الجيش والامن
والامن
والقضاء
من خلال الحكومه الانتقاليه لازم يكون فيه
عندنا
البيئه انا بدي
انا بدي
بشار الاسد
الاسرائيلي انا عم بقول لك اعاده هيكله
القضاء انا لو
اعاده هيكله الجيش والامن والقضاء
والتربيه وكتاب الدستور جديد و قوانين
وتشريعات
كلها تحتاج الى اعاده هيكليه هذه هذه ال
انا بدي قانون عادي بدي محكمه عاديه لن
اقبل بقانون استثنائي ولنا قبل ب محاكم
استثنائيه ايضا انا محامي بدي معايير
عادله للمحاكمات ايضا هذا من خلال الحكومه
الانتقاليه كله لازم يكون اذا ما في ما في
راس النظام
راس النظام يبحث وضعه
بعد المؤتمر لا هذا الكلام اللي حكى
الاستاذ
يعني استاذ
الان يعني يجب على السوريين
يعني اللي
اما بخصوص
والله الطائفه العلويه
ايضا بنفس الوقت
والضباط اللي حققوا معي علويين ودروز
معليش كمان بنفس الوقت لا الفرق العسكريه
انت بتعرف من السويد قاده فرق وقاده اجهزه
امنيه من السويد وقال وزير دفاع بدوي والى
اخره
هذه نقطه قبل ما تروح
السوريين
اربعه وعشرين
من محافظه
محافظه بالدنيا
رئيس الوزراء
رئيس الوزاره بالشارع
انا بدي سوريا ماعليش انا بدي سوريا دوله
مدنيه
مواطني دوله ودوله المواطنه لا في تمييز
بين اه على بين مواطن ومواطن على اساس
الدين او المذهب او الاثنيه او القوميه او
اي شيء بدنا نحنا عدم تمييز
الرجل يقول لك انت تقول انه تركيبه الدوله
لا يمكن ان تتغير
الدولي يمكن ان تعاد هيك كليتها على اساس
جنيف والكلام عن تسلط طائفه على بقيه ما
بيصير لازم يكون ويقول لك الرجل كل الكلام
عن انه سوريا دوله طائفيه لا اساس له من
الصحه
ما ما قاله الاستاذ
كمال
وبتنزل من السابق حسيت حالي ما عم نحكي
بكل الاحوال يا دكتور
النقاط هذه التي قالت
المشكله الاساس هذا النظام بتركيبته كلنا
نعرف ما اخواننا العالميين ومنح بين
شركاؤنا في الوطن ولكن هي تركيبه علويه
وهذا النظام محكوم من العلويه وانا اليوم
اقول لاهلنا العالميين اللي بحسب اطراف
بشار الاسد صار من خمسين الف خمسين الف
على فكره ما كانوا قاعدين الزيارات عم
يقول خمسين الف كان عم يدعونا بالدايه
وبال سلميه والدعاء
ولكن قتله الاطفال والنساء الشعب السوري
الخمسين يعني
دون الخمسين الف واللي هن اثر اثر لهذه
الخمسين الف واسر الضباط يعني
المقاتلين فرقه الرابع واستغلال الاسد
اليوم يجب ان ترضع ابناءها ويجب ان تعلم
وتطالب هي محاكم عادل الى هؤلاء اذا عندك
العداله الانتقاليه لكن في كل ما قلته
العداله الانتقاليه تبدا من راس الهرم م
من اعطى الاوامر ومن ومن نفذ ومن ايضا
للمسلم ال اعرب طهران خامنئي ومن الوكيل
التجاري للمقاومه المجرم حسن نصر الله
اللي بدها
بسوريا هدول المجرمين النظام الحاكم
وكل من يرتكب لقيت النظام الدرزي وزير
الدفاع ووزير الدفاع ورئيس الحكومه السنه
واداره الدرزي
على قدر
ليسوا ليس لهم قيمه هادول اساسا يا دكتور
الله يخليك انت تعرف انه مش مش
اليوم اليوم
الحلقه بمساعد او لها اي حاجز بالنسبه
للسيارات واذا بيحكي
انا هادي هادي لوزير الدفاع العماد علي
حبيب
عندما كان يسال ليش هاي القصص مدري شو
بيقولوا ما دخلت
وزير الدفاع
علويه لا يحق له ان يسال الاوامر اوامر
بشار الاسد
والفاعليه
عندما يقول في الاصلاح على صفحته في الفيس
بوك فى بدايه الثوره قلنا لبشار الاسد
خلينا ن في اصلاحات قال بالحرف الواحد خلي
الكلاب تنطبق على بيوت او انا
الهيكلي في وجود راس النظام الحكي اللي
حكي لكن يحتاج الى عشر سنين
ويستمر
اعيد انتاجه ال معقول مبارح بيقول لك انا
لا ارى مبرر العالم
لا يريد مائه وخمسين الف قتيل وصف سوريا
سته ملايين سبعه ملايين مهجر
بشار الاسد
يا اخي يعتبر الثاني ان شاء الله يعتبره
زلزال وحكومته تتعاطى معه يعتبروا
بالصواريخ
انتاج نظام
وجود بشار الاسد لا يمكنك ان تعيد انتاج
مديريه الصحه على حدود وكمان ما فيك بوجود
بشار الاسد لانها كلها اصبحت نظام قتل
اجرامي قمعي اليوم انت بتعرف انه رئيس
بلديه اعرب يشارك بالاكل مع النظام
انتاج يسقط هذا النظام ويرحل هذا النظام
وبعدين انا وياك والعالمي الذي لم تتلطخ
اياديه بدماء الشعب السوري الطاوله تبني
دوله دوله هلا بالفصل بشار الاسد مثل ما
عم الدستور والمجنون مثل لا يطبق هذا
الدستور على رئيس الجمهوريه الحاليه
السؤال انت تعلم ان اجهزه الامن في سوريا
فوق القانون هل تحلم فعلا بانه اجهزه
الامن فيه تحت القانون جمله واحده الاجهزه
يجب ان تتبع
المجتمع الدولي
انا طالعين بيان يا اخي مو من عندي بيان
جنيف بيقول اعاده هيكله مؤسسات خليل
السؤال على اساس هذا هل تثقون بالنظام
السوري انت بدي اسالك يومين من يومين
من يومين كان هناك صفقه لاطلاق ال الاخوان
الشيعه في في في في في لبنان
اطلق اه اه
سيدي سوريا
طيب سيدات لم يطلق سراحهم طب انت تعلم انه
هذا النظام خلال سبع دقائق تنازل لاسرائيل
وامريكا خلال اربعه وعشرين ساعه انسحاب
لبنان خلال عشر دقائق
هذا النظام
دقيقه
هذا النظام مستعد ان يتنازل لاسرائيل خلال
دقائق لكنه ليس مستعد ان يتنازل لك لن
يتنازل عن شيء
السؤال المطروح بدي اسال سؤال انت عم تقول
ليس هناك لا لا ما هو
الموضوع
الرجل يقول لك انه هناك في الاعراف
العسكريه القوي جدا لا يفاوض طيب اذا كان
النظام قويا لماذا ايران وروسيا مستقبل ان
على جنيف لنظام في حاله الجميل قال قبل
ايام الغارديان قلهن نحنا اول شيء سنطلبه
في مؤتمر جنيف وقف لاطلاق النار لانه
تماما طيب لماذا تفاوض نظامها طيب الرئيس
من كم يوم
لم يستطع ان لانه
النظام ضعيف والنظام اه مرتبه والنظام اه
كل شيء ولكن
هذا الكلام
لكن انت عم بتقولوا سنتين
القاسم
بتقولوا نفس الوقت الجيش الحر وداعش
والنصره موجودين وعم يقاتل وعم بينظر
يضربوا من كلا الطرفين اذن نحن امام حاله
سفك دماء على الارض السوريه من الجيش ومن
الاطراف الاخرى او من كل العالم انا هدفي
الاول من جنيف
وقف اطلاق القرار الدم بقرار دولي ملزم
لكل الاطراف تتبناه الدول دائمه العضويه
في مجلس الامن
هاي النقطه الاولى اثنين النظام
يعني ما عليش يا اللي
بيقدر على المسلحين
اذن نحن امام حرب عبثيه استنزاف للشعب
السوري الخاسر الوحيد فيها هو
نحنا النار قرار ملزم ملزم من دول دائمه
العضويه في مجلس الامن انه
الجسم الجسم الحكومي جنيف بالبنود السته
شي بيقول تشكيل حكومه انتقاليه بصلاحيات
دستوريه الكامله
انا بدي
امريكا
خلينا يشكل هذا الجسم الحكومي هذا الجسم
الحكومه شو مهمته مرحله انتقاليه سنه
سنتين بيطبق فيها مثل ما حكينا العداله
الانتقاليه العداله انت شو بتقول عدم
الافلات من العقاب انا ما بدي
العداله الانتقاليه عدم الافلات من العقاب
لكل من ارتكب
طبعا انا واحد من الناس عم بيكحوا على
ستين او
ان كان الجيش
اي مواطن سوري بيصير في انتهاك حق من حقوق
يجب من يمارس
الانتهاء يحاسب اول شيء الا المحاسبه
والمصالحه
والمسامحه اذن العداله الانتقاليه في
تجارب
العلويه السياسيه العلويه السياسيه هلا
نحنا
نحنا من خلال ال ال الحكومه الانتقاليه من
الاساس بدنا نرجع ناسس جديده
ما يصير انا شايف شايف انه نحنا لازم ناسس
للجمهوريه جديده في سوريا على دستور عصرى
على قوانين وتشريعات عصريه على اعاده
هيكله القضاء والجيش والامن والتربيه وكل
شيء حلو نحنا بنحلم نحنا بسوريا افضل انا
بدي سوريا افضل
انا بسالك
الرجل يتحدث منطق بصراحه بغض النظر علويه
سياسيه وتقلل مسيطرين على كذا هناك الان
اتجاه دولي هل تستطيع ان تنكر بان النظام
بات يدرك ان سوريا لا يمكن ان تعود الى
الوراء وانت تعلم مش خايف انتم العلويين
ومن السيطره العلويه من كل عاقل العلويين
بعد ما بدو يرجع واذا بدت الامور يا سيدي
خلل على ويجي على حرستا اللي يجي على
انا لا لا لا انا عم بقول لك انه انتوا
ليش خايفين الان النظام تقلع تا دراسه لن
يستطيع ان يعود ايهما افضل دمر سوريا
وتكملوا معها رجل يقول لسوريا
تعود الى ما قبل خمسطاش ثلاثه الفين وسبعه
والامر الاخر لماذا لا تنظرون الى تجارب
الربيع العربي وما قبل الربيع العربي نحن
الان في سوريا يجب ان يكون هناك عقد
اجتماعي بين كل السوريين واولهم الى
الاخوه العلويين وكل السوريين يجب ان يكون
المشاركين في عقد اجتماع جديد يجب ان لا
يستثني احد في سوريا لا يستثني احد
مثلا تعلمون من العراق في العراق اسقط
النظام في العراق صح ولا لا في العراق بكل
القوه لانه العراق لم يبد نظاما عادلا
العراق مازال يعاني امنيا واقتصاديا
وسياسيا منذ اكثر من عشر سنوات وفي سوريا
لو انتصرت انتم الان على النظام النظام
تحول الى معارضه وست ت تذهب سوريا الى
الجحيم والعكس صحيح اذن ليس امام النظام
وليس ام
اذن تجارب الربيع العربي اثبتت انه ان
ينتصر طرف على طرف النظام على المعارضه
ولا المعارضه على النظام يجب ان يكون هناك
عقد اجتماع جديد لكل السوريين اولا ياسيدي
لم يحدث تجربه بالربيع العربي مشابهه
السوري
بشار الاسد الذي تجاوز كل الخطوط الحمراء
بالنسبه لمساله العقد الاجتماعي مع اخوتنا
العلويين انا منذ بدايه الصوره حتى الان
اذا انا غلطان صحح لي استاذ محمود اللي
فاتوا ويذبحون
يقول لك حادثه ارتكبتها مجموعات غير
منضبطه ولا يوجد لهم اي غطاء وانا مثلك
النادي محاكمتهم لكن
اللي عملوا
قتل مين ما كان يكون
الا في حاله الدفاع عن النفس
عندما تقول يعني عندما تقول استاذ وقف
اطلاق النار وقف اطلاق النار ليس دائما هو
مبرر سفك الدماء والسبب وقف اطلاق النار
في كثير من الاحيان يكون مناسبه دفاع وهو
يوقف القتل يعني بشار الاسد ما فيه جيش حر
اداريه
والمعظميه
كان هلا سمعت مليون شهيد باي المناطق تحت
جنازير الدبابات بشار الاسد مثل ما صار
وقت على السلطه على على
على ال على ال على على اداريه مثل ما صار
فيه عندما دخل الى يظهرها قتل اطفال ونساء
الرجال
هذه ليبيا انظر الى الفوضى ليبيا لان رئيس
الوزراء لم يتوصلوا الى عقد اجتماع جديد
يشمل الجميع الماضي والسابق تستطيع ان
في سوريا
نظام حكم النظام مبارك بسوريا في شويه
مرتزقه كل واحد
ما لا يوجد نظام حسني مبارك هذا الحكي كان
عنده عمرو موسى عنده البرادعي عندهم نظام
حكم وزراء ما حدا عنده مجموعه قتل
ارهابيين قتلوا الشعب السوري يعني
عقد اجتماعي حكومه
المصالحه الاجتماعيه ولا
وزير شؤون الطفل يعني
الرئيس
الاجتماعي الاجتماعيه بعدما يا دكتور
تجاوزوا بالقتل لم يتركوا ولا ولا الجامع
ولكن بناء البيت دمروا كل شيء وبالتالي
عقد اجتماعي والعلويه والمجرمين نحن لم
يكن يوما لم يعرفها يوما للشعب السوري
الطائفيه الاعلى دور المجرم الشارع الاسد
لم يكن يوما الى ما نقول اخواننا العناوين
اذا انت بالنسبه لك
كما اطلع طائفي لا يا اخي طائفي ممنوع
بشار الاسد صباح مائه وخمسين الف سنه لا
يجوز امام نظر ومسمع العالم العربي كله
هذا الكلام غير مقبول لا تقبل ولا شرعيه
ولا قوانين
انا انا انا مثلك اشعر باهل الجوي واريد
ان يوقف القتل اريد ان يوقف القاتل عن سفك
الدماء السوريين اريد ان يوقف
يعني
بالنتيجه بلديه مثل ما هي بلدك اللي انا
بدي اعيش فيها ولادي فيه وبدي الناس ترجع
بيوت
الشجر قبوله انه انا اقول اولا انه الجيش
الحر لانه بشار الاسد الحاصل المعظم
هلا في شغل او لا نريد ان حاله نحن نريد
الحل نريد وقف سفك الدماء لكن
يبدا من ال والمساله والمشكله في سوريا
على نقطه عندما يقول الرئيس السوري بالامس
ليس هناك ما نعم
يا اخي يا اخي ليس هناك مانع من الترشح
معارضه
اولا
واذا ما في جنيف المفروض انها جنيف لانه
ما في مجال الا بالحل السياسي
والعسكري بالقتال
انتحر
حل سياسي تراجع المعتقلين نساهم في
معتقلين بسوريا افراج عنون في مناطق
محاصره يجب ان يصل اليها الدواء والغذاء
يعني يعملون الاخرين
يعني
المشكله الان خليني اكمل
الغذاء والدواء لكل المناطق
ما بيصير ما بيصير مواطن سوري
ماذا تريد ان تقول ان الحل السياسي هو
الاساس ولا حل عسكري في سوريا ماذا تقول
بجمله واحده سيبقى الشعب السوري مهما فعل
بشار الاسد شامخ شموخ قاسيون مهما جمع
وجود ومهما قتلوا ما يسقط بشار الاسد جنيف
ودول جنيف ولن نكون شركاء في تبريد قتل
اهله واعطاء شرعيه للقاتل المجرم بشار
الاسد في جنيف ولا غيره الكرام
سيد محمود
[موسيقى]